6 une piquure sur le bout du doigt même
pas le temps de prendre sa respiration
et c'est fait Martine CLIRE est venu
tester son taux de sucre dans le sang
son niveau de diabète parce que la
dernière fois j'avais je trouvais un
taux un petit peu élevé le matin à jeun
par le
laboratoire donc j'ai voulu recontrôler
et alors ça donnait quoi ah bah c'est
parfait aujourd'hui c'est parfait 110
donc ça doit être bon pour quelqu'un qui
vient de qui a déjeuné il y a moins de 2
he donc c'est parfait moi aussi c'est
parfait ont le sourire tant mieux en
France on estime à 3 millions et demi le
nombre de diabétiques dont 500000
s'ignorerit les risques sont pour temps
réel on va avoir tous les risques
cardiovasculaires tous les risques bah
justement dans quand on parle de risque
cardiovasculaire et de complications ça
va forcément toucher tout ce qui est
petit vaisseau et gros vaisseau et donc
entraîner des problèmes que ce soit au
niveau des yeux au niveau des reins au
niveau du cœur il existe deux types de
diabète le diabète de type 1 qui touche
les enfants et les adolescents et le
diabète de type 2 qui concerne les plus
de 40 ans mais qui atteint de plus en
plus de jeunes en cause la sédentarité
et la malbouffe les conseils de
prévention sont évidents d'avoir une
activité physique d'équilibrer ses repas
ce qui n'est pas facile pour tous vu la
conjoncture actuelle que nous
rencontrons dans dans la société pour
nos jeunes diabétiques c'est avoir un
équilibre puisque pour le diabète de
type 1 malheureusement nos jeunes sont
tout de suite traités par insuline donc
c'est d'adapter leur traitement à leur
vie de tous les jours et de continuer à
vivre normalement avec une hygiène de
vie le diabète est une maladie du
pancréas elle est invisible mais il y a
des signes qui doivent prévenir comme un
certain amaigrissement une soif
importante un besoin d'uriner et un
manque d'attention pour les plus jeunes
enfants rel